la chronique de l'environnement avec
Valérie oribo bonsoir Valérie et ce soir
focus sur les rencontres de poigné avec
votre invité oui absolument nous
recevons Françoise Vernin Vernet
Aubertin pardon bonsoir vous êtes
présidente de l'association donc les
rencontres de poignis une association
qui met en place des actions de
sensibilisation à l'écologie à
l'environnement et à l'économie sociale
et solidaire et vendredi dernier 15
février vous organiser un débat
notamment autour de du documentaire the
end of the line l'océan en voie
d'épuisement c'est un thème toujours
d'actualité malgré les nombreuses
alertes de la part des écologistes et
des scientifiques alors c'est un thème
qui est plus que d'actualité en ce
moment à bruxel à l'Europe est en train
de se négocier on va dire les lois qui
vont régir la pêche en Europe et ce
documentaire permet de sensibiliser la
population mélanie Laurent est une des
ambassadrices organ oranise elle aussi
un certain nombre de de débats il y
avait 120 personnes vendredi 15 à poigni
et c'était vraiment l'occasion
d'échanger et je pense de toucher du
doigt des sujets qu'on voit pas
quotidiennement un des intervenants du
film disait si dans un restaurant au
menu il y avait de Laurent outant on
plastiquerait le restaurant aujourd'hui
il y a du temps on fait rien parce que
on ne sait pas en fait c'est une
méconnaissance de la raréfaction de
cette espèce aujourd'hui dans les océans
partout dans le monde alors ce qu'il y a
dans dans nos assiettes intéresse
particulièrement la l'association
puisque en novembre dernier vous aviez
déjà fait un un sujet en en corrélation
avec le le le jeune et la santé ex
exactement on a reçu deux personnes
Sylvie gilm et Thierry de l'estrade qui
sont deux réalisateurs qui avaient fait
pour haré un excellent documentaire qui
s'appelle le jeune thérapeutique on
était à peu près 90 ou 95 personnes et à
cette occasion là on a pu débattre en
fait des recherches des scientifiques
notamment aux
États-Unis sur le lien entre le jeûne
thérapeutique et certains cancers voilà
donc il y a un livre qui est en
préparation qui sortira en septembre sur
ce sujet-là et on avait la chance
d'avoir des personnes qui étaient venues
qui étai qui avaient jeûé et qui sont
venus témoigner et échanger puisque les
gens avaient plein de questions puisque
il y a de plus en plus d'articles
là-dessus dans la presse et rencontrer
des gens qui l'ont fait ça démystifie un
petit peu cette aventure d'accord alors
la santé c'est quelque chose qui nous
touche tous de très très près TVfil
s'est également intéressé à la pollution
des villes et à la corrélation avec la
santé reportage en image d'elodim
moine industrie automobile ou encore
chauffage les principaux responsables de
la pollution qui nous entoure le souffre
l'oxyde d'azote l'ozone et les
particules qui s'en échappent forment
les pollouants que nous respirons au
quotidien plus ces particules sont fines
plus elle pénètre dans les poumons et
plus les conséquences sont importantes
sur la santé au sein de l'université de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline les médecins
constatent une augmentation des
pathologies on va dire strictement
respiratoires des pathologies
cardiovasculaires peut avoir des
déclenchements de de de d'infarctus ou
éventuellement des des d'ugmentation des
décès et puis aussi on a trouvé des fois
des risques augmentés de d'accidents
vasculaires cérébraux appel des des
attaques hein voilà parmi les
populations les plus exposées les
enfants dont le système respiratoire
n'est pas mature ce qui engendre une
augmentation des bronchiolites les
personnes âgées dont les fonctions
vitales sont amoindries les fumeurs dont
les poumons sont déjà fragilisés du fait
de leur tabagisme les sportifs dont les
efforts respiratoires sont accrus et les
femmes enceintes qui se trouvent dans
une situation de consommation de
ressources augmenté mais l'air n'est pas
le seul espace pollué l'eau que nous
buvons en magasine aussi des polluants
onrouve des concentrations
d'antibiotiques onouve des
concentrations de de produits chimiques
à des niveaux qui peuvent être faible
mais encore une fois s'il y a pas
d'effet soil je dire même des niveaux
faibles répétés absorber régulièrement
pe peuvent avoir un effet et là on a un
domaine qui s'appelle le domaine des
perturbateurs endocriniens c'est des
produits qui vont modifier les le
fonctionnement hormonal notamment des
des personnes cette contamination de
l'eau pourrait être l'une des pistes
engendrant la baisse de la fertilité dès
aujourd'hui les espaces urbains doivent
être repensés il est impératif de
développer l'urbanisme les espaces verts
l'organisation des transports et le
développement d'emplois locaux dans un
même schéma pour répondre au problème de
pollution sur la
santé alors vous disiez justement
pendant le sujet vous aviez aussi fait
des soirées sur l'eau sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens
oui en fait on essaie de faire des
sujets qui finalement
intéresse le grand public et qui souvent
sont compliqués et vraiment l'ambition
de de de ces rencontres qui sont des
lieux conviviaux he puisque l'idée c'est
pas de dénoncer tous les problèmes de la
planète et de repartir plus chargé qu'on
est arrivé c'est d'arriver à démystifier
et à rencontrer des personnes qui
simplement peuvent expliquer voilà donc
c'est vraiment le c'est vraiment
l'objectif et donc sur l'eau on avit
fait un sujet sur la qualité de l'eau
puisqu'on se pose tous la question quand
on ouvre notre obiné de la qualité de
l'eau robiné mais la question des
solutions aussi parce que vous vous
rassurez pas seulement vous inquiétez
aussi parfois avec certains problème
qu'on soupçonne pas ce sont des réalités
mais ça crée aussi des des inquiétudes
est-ce qu'il y a des solutions qu'on
peut qu'on peut y apporter des
comportements à changer oui oui voilà
l'idée c'est des comportement on on
distribue souvent des informations par
exemple sur la pêche durable il y a
aujourd'hui des documents édités
notamment par des associations
environnemental en fait sur les
différentes espèces celles qui sont à
privilégié tout simplement pour que
l'océan et les réserves aliotiques se
régénèent donc évitons de consommer
certains poissons et consomm certains
autres poissons qui ne sont pas gênants
donc l'idée c'est vraiment d'arriver
avec des solution parce que je trouve
que les problèmes on en a suffisamment
au quotidien euh voilà alors justement
wilfri parlait d'inquiétude mais est-ce
que les gens ne sont pas justement de
plus en plus Friant de vérité
d'information ce qui les concerne je
pense que les gens sont de plus en plus
responsables en fait on les met face à
le responsabilité la santé qui est un
des sujets que vous avez traité là avec
les perturbateurs endocriniens je pense
que l'idée c'est de responsabiliser les
gens c'est pas je suis malade tiens je
vais voir le docteur sans me poser la
question de savoir exactement ce qui se
passe donc les gens sont plus
curieux et moi je vois dans le profil
des personnes qui viennent c'est hommes
femmes jeunes âgés des enfants voilà il
y a pas de de
clivage c'est évident que l'univers dans
lequel on vit médiatique amène des
questions il y a de plus en plus de
livres qui sortent et et et là l'idée
c'est c'est de c'est de se rencontrer
plutôt que d'être seul chez soi et de
débattre de ces questions qui
préoccupent alors cette association est
née en 2010 comment est née cette
association en fait l'association elle
est née au départ part puisqu'on a
souhaité passer une partie de la cantine
du village en bio euh voilà et j'ai
proposé d'organiser une soirée avec un
film qui s'appelle nos enfants nous
accuseront donc en septembre pour que
les parents viennent débattre avec nous
et puis ben voilà face à à l'engouement
moi j'avais très envie parce que j'avais
déjà dans ma vie professionnelle passé
organiser des rencontres bah me dire à
l'échelle d'un village finalement on est
900 habitants si on organise des des
rencontres on peut se on peut se
retrouver et on on a passé de je sais
pas 30 40 à aujourd'hui 100 150 l'année
dernière on était 200 en janvier sur des
questions autour de la démocratie voilà
donc c'est c'est ça qui nous a animé en
fait dans l'organisation de ces soirées
oui parce que justement ces soirées sont
organisées généralement autour d'un
documentaire et après les visiteurs
viennent débattre avec les scientifiques
les chercheurs exactement donc le clou
c'est le documentaire en général un 52
minutes ce qui permet à chacun d'avoir
un minimum d'information partagé sinon
on arrive et des fois on sait pas trop
ce que ça veut dire par exemple la
viticulture en biodynamie au mois
d'octobre si on n'est pas allé se
renseigner avant c'est peut-être un peu
difficile donc il y a un documentaire et
derrière en général je fais intervenir
soit les réalisateurs soit des experts
soit des des acteurs locaux parce que je
trouve que sur le territoire on a plein
de richesses et donc j'avais organisé un
débat sur les abeilles par exemple et
j'en refais un là au mois de juin et du
côté de de Gif du côté d'orsé il y a des
scientifiques il y a des apiculteurs
même à Saint-Léger il y a une
association qui s'appelle les appis
culteurs appis ha de P grec et donc
voilà l'idée c'est aussi de faire
intervenir des gens localement je trouve
que c'est c'est une opportunité de se
rencontrer on sait souvent pas ce que
fait son voisin et là c'est l'occasion
de se voilà de se rencontrer sur
d'autres lieux différents rendez-vous
qui sont proposés le prochain
rendez-vous ce sera le prochain
rendez-vous donc ce sera le 12 avril
prochain avec la projection d'un
documentaires les industries extractives
et les droits de l'homme c'est tout un
programme voilà là on va partir au
Nigéria et on va aller voir comment le
pétrole est extrait et surtout bah les
droits de l'homme dans tout ça voilà
donc on aura l'ancien président
d'amnestie International France qui
s'appelle Francis Perin qui sera présent
donc un débat à nouveau passionnant très
bien donc ce sera pour le 12 avril donc
à Poigny exactement voilà toujours
pareil la salle du maris route de
Rambouillet voilà merci à vous d'être
venu nous présenter votre votre travail
sur ce plateau on poursuit avec une
information dans cette chronique de
l'environnement autour du Salon de
l'Agriculture qui se déroule jusqu'à la
fin de la semaine porte de versaill à
Paris et les produits laitiers des
ivelines distingués oui absolument
l'Île-de-France se distingue au Salon
International de l'Agriculture ces
médailles attribuées récompensent le
savoir-faire des producteurs de la
région et témoingent de la richesse du
patrimoine francilien alors la ferme de
trembla à à la Boissière école a reçu
une médaille d'argent pour son fromage
de chèvre à patemol et à croûte
fleuri c'est si poétique même médaille
d'argent pour la fesselle fermière du
domaine de grgnon et côté médaillé de
bronze se distingue le domaine de
Grignon toujours avec ses yaourts
aromatisés à la vanille et aux abricots
on passe à l'agenda à présent dans cette
chronique de l'environnement jeis
perturbé par les
fromages à une randonnée proposée par la
Ligue de Protection des Oiseaux dimanche
3 mars de 9h à 12h afin de découvrir les
oiseaux du parc des sources de la Bièvre
une rencontre animée par une bénévole de
la Ligue et puis côté architecture la
Maison de l'environnement propose un
atelier le mercredi 6 mars construit ton
habitat spectaculaire avec des capelas
c'est un un atelier animé par le Centre
capelas pour les petits architecte des 3
ans oui les CAPL c'est mignon pour les
plus jeunes voilà pour les faire un
petit atelier les moins jeunes
d'ailleurs aussi merci Valérie prochaine
chronique de l'environnement mardi
prochain 18h30 il est bientôt 18h45 si
vous nous suivez en direct sur TVfil
dans le 78 nous allons recevoir Bertrand
Révillon journaliste auteur de
conversation spirituelles nous en
parlerons tout à l'heure avec lui nous
parlerons religion mais pas seulement
vous le verrez mais du sport tout
d'abord du hand fauteuil avec ce
reportage consacré à une opération qui
s'est déroulé en marge du quart de
finale de la Coupe de la Ligue de
handball féminin à plaisir nous en
avions parlé sur cette antenne voici ce
qui s'est passé juste avant la
rencontre des joueurs valident sur rou
lors d'un match de handball ou plus
précisément de hand fauteuil les
plaisiris ont découvert ce sport
mercredi dernier en levé de rideau du
quart de finale de Coupe de la Ligue de
handball féminin plusieurs fois j'ai
j'ai fait des marchés parce que c'est
vrai que on n pas gérer fauteuil plus
driblé c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
les règles sont un petit peu différentes
et on se rend compte que c'est vrai au
niveau des bras ça fatigue ça fatigue
vraiment c'est vraiment une autre
manière de voir le hand les joueurs
valides du club inimontain participent à
une séance de hand fauteuil tous les
premiers mardis du mois et apparemment
ils apprennent vite au début ils
souffrent c'est ça qui est bien mais
quand ils deviennent bons c'est eux à
leur tour qui se brangent les règles de
jeu sont les mêmes que chez les valides
par exemple le marché est sifflé après
trois poussées de roues et la
spécificité la plus visible fauteuil et
le réducteur de but cette planche rouge
plac sous la BAR transversale des cages
avir la B DRI le fauteuil éviter
l'adversaire avoir une bonne vision de
jeu qui est tout pour l'instant cette
discipline souffre d'un énorme manque de
reconnaissance il n a que de équipes en
île-defance don mon le
BR